[موسيقى]
مع تبادل الاتهامات بشان الطرف المسؤول عن
ما حدث في سدك خوفكى فان الثابته ان مياه
السد تبدلت من مصدر حياه الى خطر كبير قد
يتعدى حدود الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه يفصل نهر
دنيبر بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه خرسون لكن ضرره كان واحدا على
اراضي ضفتي وكل من يقطن فيها استنادا الى
رئيس الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه فيرسون
فان متوسط ارتفاع المياه بلغ اكثر من خمسه
امتار ونصف المتر وغمرت الاف المنازل هكذا
بدا المشهد عبر الاقمار الصناعيه لبلده
اوليسكي قبل الفيضان وبعده
يقول المسؤول الاوكراني ان المياه غمرت
600 كيلومتر مربع من اراضي منطقه خرسون
بنسبه 32% في منطقه سيطره الاوكرانيين و
68% من منطقه سيطره القوات الروسيه وفق
تقارير فان المنطقه المتضرره يسكنها نحو
40 الف شخص سيكونون نازحين وبدون مصدر رزق
لسنوات بالنظر الى جرف اراضيهم الزراعيه
ومنازلهم عدا عن تلوث النهر ب 150 طنا من
زيوت التشحيم الصناعيه استنادا الى ما
قاله الرئيس الاوكراني ايضا فان مسؤولا في
الصليب الاحمر الدولي تحدث عن فقدانهم
باماكن وجود الالغام الارضيه وتحركها
جنوبا مع مياه الفيضان
هذه الصور لحقول في بلده كرينكي وهي تفسر
ما اشارت اليه وزاره الزراعه الاوكرانيه
باحتمال خساره ملايين الاطنان من المحاصيل
الزراعيه واحتمال تصحر المنطقه جراء في
تربتها
ليس الزرع الموجود فحسب بل حتى ما حصد منه
قبلا فصوانع تخزين الحبوب كان لها نصيب من
الغمر ايضا على هذا يتعدى الخطر حسب تقدير
برنامج الغذاء العالمي الى ابعد من
المنطقه وساكنها اذ يشمل نحو 30045 مليون
شخص حول العالم بسبب غمر الفيضانات للحبوب
المزروعه حديثا كما ان اسعار السوق
العالميه للسلع الغذائيه وفق البرنامج
الاممي وصلت الى اعلى مستوى لها منذ عشره
اعوام